you I mean you've worked with so many
interesting people through the years so
many great co-stars both the comedic
stuff and it's the serious stuff who are
some of the actors that you've worked
with that it it became a friendship that
means a lot to you or maybe it's a
connection that you have with them that
professionally you like I think Chris
Tucker yeah
even even though I don't like him the
beginning tell us about that part first
time I met him in William Morris office
and he just keep talking as you look at
that guy why why he's keep talking and I
you know and he's so fast you know
mostly people like Brett Ratner and like
like my manager Jackie the movie is
really good for you I understand no and
crystal codec I don't ha ha ha I just ah
uh-huh
ha ha ha then after he laughs yeah ha ha
after left then I asked my man
what the hell we talking about I don't I
don't even one word no come under cut
from his mouth and later on he using the
movie and it's too young and too young
and come to the set so many idea and he
was late on the set I was seven o'clock
call I was at 6:30 I already make up
standing be I'm filmmaker they are
standing here then he just come 11 hour
car
allez-y a lay and lay and step one day
he come to my open Oh Jackie can you
come later yeah you make me look bad as
no that's my job no you have to write to
come late did you did you did you no I
said no I'm a director I can I can come
late and I'm an actor after on the set
that's my job
but now Chris
every day on the set and do what just do
the really really good things now I
really like him yeah but now he's just
understand you know and follow the rule
or the now he's great you know mostly
time tsukitachi where are you I said I
mean Hong Kong okay when you come to
United as they're coming soon a week of
giant together as okay okay